hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast steps on the route to
optimizing experimental design including
teaching and conducting systematic
reviews and Judy Oracle lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots so we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
on the get your free CD credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations so
please select the CD button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate this webcast
is designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the green shoe and
a button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speakers Derek fry
faculty of life sciences university of
manchester and Rob Therese PhD
scientific researcher and coordinator
circle at the central animal laboratory
at Brown University Medical Center dr.
Frey is a medical doctor and also Doctor
of Philosophy who's been interested in
experimental design since it since
including statistics when his medical
student teaching in 1980s he continued
that interest when he moved to UK
government work which involves assessing
proposals for animal experiments in many
different fields and advising on
biomedical issues in animal based
research and testing on retiring he was
granted an honorary position at the
University of Manchester and has been
running or helping run workshops on
experimental design in the UK in various
countries in Europe Asia and North
America and exploring how to teach the
subject interesting and entertaining way
more on his background can be found on
the lab roots website doctor DeVries
studied biology and philosophy and as a
PhD in the ethics of animal
experimentation as a postdoctoral
researcher he studied the application of
the three RS to teach tissue engineering
research doctor DeVries has been a
member of two Animal Ethics Committee
his reach research is always focused on
the intersection between ethics and
nessa logical aspects of animal
experiments he currently works as a
scientific researcher and coordinator at
Circle the systematic review center for
a laboratory animal experimentation in
nijmegen the netherlands is mainly
responsible for organizing hands-on
training in systematic reviews of animal
studies and for coaching researchers who
are conducting their own systematic
reviews I will now turn it over to dr.
fry for his presentation okay well we're
gonna start with is looking at what you
need think of in terms of optimizing
experimental design and then I'll go on
to the way in which you might teach
these various things basically I operate
on the idea that in order to teach
something you need to work out very
closely what it is those receiving the
teaching needs to know to prioritize it
and give some idea therefore aware that
they ought to be putting the effort in
terms of studying for an optimizing
experimental design I think there are a
number of principles you need to pick up
first of all are the ethical principles
and then the basis of providing results
that are valid reliable reproducible and
as widely applicable as you can manage
that you would expect an optimal
experimental design to be efficient in
use of animals and resources and to
minimize also the impact on the animal
with the veritable procedures and the
distress from the housing and that sort
of thing so
the fourth step i think in optimizing is
to recognize what is needed and i think
that means a clear objective getting
minimal severity from what you're doing
designing to get good valid reproducible
results and also not just taking one
experimental time but planning sequences
of experiments as you get minimal
severity overall and of course for each
experiment getting the right numbers and
the right type of design so great
experiment you might think that
specifying the objective thinking about
that obvious deciding what maybe you
should take on which are the better ones
considering how you get the best effect
and minimize the variability identifying
the experiment unit in it that's a term
which you're not used to we define it a
bit later and we then family
experimental design thinking about what
controls you need what the test
alterations you're going to study what
are the constraints and then how you
allocate the experimental units so you
decide how to analyze results on that
basis taking an acceptable level of
significance that is false positives and
power which is the ability to detect
genuine positives and estimating the
group size on that basis so later were
sort of hold patents but really it's
important that you also have an idea of
the fundamental principles and keep them
one we've already mentioned which is
having good and suitable relevant
unusually concurrent controls another is
to repeat the biological units
efficiently often to get a good
indication of this very distinctions
between groups which have had different
experimental treatments but you also
need to make site quite sure that you
have assigned those particular
biological units at random otherwise you
introduce some color bias and it's not
just when you're in signing but also
randomizing whatever there might be a
possible bias throughout the experiment
and this relationship to the
experimental unit is key to working out
both the replicas as they're called and
how to randomly assign and you can
define the experimental unit as a
repetition unit all that part of the
biological material that can be
independently assigned to any of the
experimental treatments for example if
you have this type of approach you're
looking at whether compounded
teratogenic and you assign a number of
pregnant rats to control groups or to
one of three dose levels of the compound
evolved in vehicle and then on day 18
gestation you kill the rats and remove
the fetuses and examined red normalities
what is the experiment unit there I what
can be independently assigned to a
particular experiment manipulation or
treatment what do you think it was
pregnant at the base level the fetus or
is episode of thing you're not sure
about well basically what is assigned to
different treatments is the pregnant rat
so that is the experimental unit in this
particular situation and then of course
you need to get perfect controls and I
think the way of looking at it is to
think about what the objectives
experiment is because if it's simply to
compare one procedure as another you
don't necessarily need a separate
sham-operated or a vehicle injected
control you're just comparing the two
procedures and don't think what the
outcomes and the experiment might be
think what the interpretations could be
and then think what controls are needed
to avoid misinterpretation in particular
and beware of taking a negative
result from the test manipulation as
though it was a genuine negative unless
you have got some positive control or
other good reason for taking it up and
of course randomization it is the idea
of and migration is to make sure that
any inherent problems in your material
is randomly assigned or equal
probability of going into any of your
treatment groups so you don't get a
mix-up of that property with a
particular treatment and the idea is to
avoid bias and make quite certain or
what you're getting is a spread of other
differences in the different groups that
you're comparing the CV effective
treatment but of course it needs to
apply to every state because it's not
just allocation or selection but also
when you expose to a test operation when
you arranged within an environment where
there may be gradients of lighting or
heating and in the oldest measurement
because in both of them giving an agent
and in measuring result though the
liability for you as a person who's
being it to have a certain amount of
drift in terms of your experience and
your degree of tiredness and how near or
far you are from a coffee break and that
sort of thing and the problems you find
going round if many scientists don't
know how to randomize prop properly
you've ever get biased results and
you've now got a complete literature
which is looking at the problem of a
quality of published studies in terms of
random assignment and grinding of the
person who's scoring the outcome to the
treatment that the biological material
has had also people don't plan sequences
of experiments unless they're stimulated
to do so and you don't think take into
account the 3-yard aspect whether there
are
for roiling animal use or for making
procedures which are lesser severity and
having access to experimental type in
Eastern Europe is comparatively rare and
if it does it comes from statisticians
and they tend to be thinking about the
efficiency of design and the numbers and
so on and not necessarily on the
severity of a possibility you might have
to exclude animals on the basis of the
degree of adverse effects they're
experiencing so a third step i think is
recognizing that so the experimental
design is not just minimizing numbers
but it looks at whether where that
possibility is really sweet whether
you're getting pain on the stress that
may think the data and what and the
animal side of it may have as an effect
on your outcomes but also you need to
think about whether you're using humane
endpoints I cutoff points at which we
animal is take off experiment because of
either the severity of the intervention
or some other reason has made it
impossible to carry on and you need to
have designs which are robust to that
sort of lost if it is a risk and the
fourth one I think is to have a very
clear idea what you're doing because
unless you have a clear objective you
can't assess whether the experiment
should be a proper testing hypothesis
experiment or whether you need some more
data whether you actually meet these
animals for a particular objective and
what will be suitable controls but
equally you can't decide when it should
be stopped because you've achieved be
objective or you found that it's
impossible to do it and you need to stop
Rev any further and severity or wastage
of animals but also you can't design
efficiently without a clear objective
I step 5 i think is to try and see how
you can maximize the effect and minimize
the variability because that has a large
effect on the number of animals you need
and the more animals you need to less
optimal on the considerate what you can
do is increase they think size by
getting good measurements giving not a
stimulus using more sensitive subjects
and so on or you can decrease the
variability usually by improving
uniformity standardizing or using what
is called a covariant approach or
improving the experimental design so it
takes into account sources of
variability that are not from the
experimental manipulations if you can't
do any of that you need to increase the
sample size in order to make sure that
you do pick up a genuine effect and
variability has this strange thing but
if you have a look at that graph and
which is taken with big parameters to
the right there so it's a two-sample
comparison and that gives you for that
measure of their ability to standard
deviation there around point for a size
for each of the two groups compared or
something like eight experimental units
may be in each and if you have more
variability then you will need to have
larger numbers and less variability
swimmer numbers but if you look at the
variability of point six standard
deviation you find you need nearly 20
animals per group you drop that 2.3 and
you only need five animals so really a
squared effect here and the royalty cup
of variability but largely thank you
have on the size of the group's you need
to compare and let on the animal use and
that's also true more complex designs
such as this I'm 2 by 2 factorial
and having mentioned a couple of designs
let's have a look at what they might be
fully random is simple to lure more
group comparisons randomized block get a
certain amount of ability to distinguish
variability which is not due to the
experimental conditions and factorial is
where you're interested in two or more
elements that configure guarded that
both are part of your experimental
outcome and repeat measures is taking
several measures on one experimental
unit sequential is i'm looking at a
little experiment seeing its result
doing another one which is the same or
very similar and comparing that result
and building this up until you reach
certain cutoff points which you set
beforehand and these all have plus and
minuses to them the first one is one
much so many people use it as well
understood a little problem but you
don't get any control of variability
which is not due to the differences
between treatments the randomized bomb
does give you some of that control as a
variability which is not cute attributes
and but it means you lose a certain
amount of power tight oil is looking at
two different things or more at once and
gives you a lot of information provision
so the amount of experimental units you
use but it can get too complex the peak
major comes out individual variation
that you have to be very careful that if
you're using different time periods like
there is no crossover between the two
treatment time periods and sequential is
very good for minimizing the animal use
that you need to be very careful how you
do it and I really used a couple of
terms one is factor which is really just
the source of their ability or discrete
idealistic and treatment the different
and experimental manipulations gender
strain later that day what sort of thing
can be used to thank this and blocking
it essentially a pattern of grouping
according to a possible source of
variability so let's consider a
randomized block design in which you do
a stratified random arrangement all the
treatments occur in each grouping so
you're comparing the treatments within a
group inc or block and the sum of the
values within each block or the average
if you want to go that way will include
the contribution from each treatment the
variability between the thumbs or
averages from each block is not due to
treatment that is due to something else
and therefore you can see it and take it
out of the mathematics you're using to
compare different groups and this is a
sort of thing you might do a randomized
block in which you're using different
surgical treatments which you're
preparing and here you've got time for
ABCD blocks of time which may be
different days of a week or different
due to an uncle that sort of thing but
the important thing is that during each
time period every one of the first for
surgical treatment is occurring and
another illustration is to use litter if
you are looking at two different diets
and the effect on the top them from
different letters you might people
together like this and get not to
greater separation but if you leave
before hand what letters they came for
you might well find you've got the
differences in the litters which are not
obvious from the overall pattern between
different groupings so here the rig a it
already wiped a is about the white see
the black is above the black the info on
and that means you can now see that
there is no
diet where it was not clear when you had
grouped everything together irrespective
of which later they came from fan toil
experiment and looking at trying to get
app information and from several things
at once and they helped to show a
generality of the findings because they
are effectively doing to experiment in
one and to make that a bit clearer here
is a single factor design where you're
comparing treatment a md a and B are
different levels of effective treatment
you've got eight experimental units in
each one and you might want to compare
two strains so you might go that way and
repeat the experiment of a second
strength so you use twice as many
animals but thanked all approaches to go
this way and in the comparison of
treatments have half of them in strain
eight and half of them it's in strain d
that way you can compare the strains
sorry one and two against the treatments
a and B and you can from the whole
experiment work out whether you have
significant differences because you're
using all the experimental units to
determine the variability the individual
subgroups can actually be a lot smaller
and you might think but also the
advantage of this if there is effective
one factor on the other which is called
interaction you can see it so I think
dr. knife a researcher needs that clear
and testable hypotheses to understand
how to obtain valid reliable results
using adequate and appropriate controls
a correct identification of experimental
unit and avoiding bias throughout but I
also needs the skill to pick an
appropriate and efficient design
understanding how to minimize stability
because of the effects ability has on
the quality of the data how does one get
this across have you decided if that is
what you need to get across how we do
set one way of course is to prevent it
in such a way that people can remember
it and understand why you're arguing for
particular approach another way is to
get them to look at the tech sort of
problems and see how they would identify
experimental units for example arrange
experimental units within different
treatments and judge the presentation of
the outcomes and all of those you can
use as a way of improving people's
skills at identifying what to do in
particular expose their own particular
experimental situations and normally
what you would do is also have a
discussion a tutorial type concussion or
facilitated discussion which considers
the impact on the animals and how you
might be able to come right down and cut
also the variability between and I think
it's important to have an assessment
which is not worrisome so that it is
some degree what they have to think
about it but there is no scoring you
don't humiliate anyone in a group
situation and you don't show anyone up
in a scoring situation so you allow them
to think about it and the one they want
the answer is but you never put them in
the position where a wrong answer look
stupid I think that's a suitable point
to finish and park on the robber thank
you dr. fry for the informative
presentation we will now hear from dr.
degrees and I will turn the priests in a
presentation over to him
thank you very much
now in my lecture I want to discuss how
a certain type of literature review a
so-called systematic review can be
helpful in designing new animal
experiments and for those of you who
have not been able to look at these
lectures by my colleagues mill viscous
and a line or mumps I want to ever so
briefly explain the concept of a
systematic review before I discuss how
it can be helpful for designing
experiments now here is a common
definition of the concept of a
systematic review it's the process of
systematically locating appraising and
synthesizing evidence from scientific
studies in order to obtain a reliable
overview so key features our systematic
review our comprehensiveness you want to
be as complete as possible and
transparency to describe in detail how
you conduct the different steps of your
review it's important to distinguish
between the concept of a systematic
review and the concept of a
meta-analysis they are sometimes used as
synonyms but they are really different
concepts a meta-analysis is a
combination of outcome data from
individual studies and you combine those
results in an overall statistical
analysis it's important that
systemically you can contain a
meta-analysis that it's not necessary
for example if the outcome measures in
the individual studies included in your
systematic review are two different it
doesn't make sense to combine them in
one analysis and then you have a
perfectly sensible systematic review but
it does not contain a meta-analysis and
here are the steps of which a systematic
review typically consists you start by
praising the research question of your
review and based on that research
question you start searching for all
evidence that might be relevant to that
question based on the studies you find
you select the studies that are really
relevant to your question and you do so
on the basis of explicit inclusion and
exclusion criteria once you've
identified the studies that are really
relevant for your research question you
expect the main characteristics of those
studies you assess the methodological
quality of those studies so how reliable
the results of those studies are and if
possible you combine the outcome data in
a meta-analysis if you want to know more
about the concept of systematic review
you can look at the video scribe there's
a link at the bottom of the slide and
there you can learn more about the
concept but I now want to turn to what
systematic reviews can do for
experimental design in my view system LP
who's can contribute to experimental
design in a number of different ways and
on the most general level systematic
reviews are very suitable to identify
knowledge gaps in a systematic review
you create a comprehensive overview of
all available evidence on a certain
topic and so almost by definition after
review you know which questions have
already been answered in the literature
and which questions are still open and
the open questions of course can become
the research questions for new
experiments but I think system reviews
can also help in more specific ways and
the first one and by optimizing the
design and the context of translational
research many animal experiments are
carried out to inform human health and
to get information about human disease
but it's becoming increasingly clear
that it's anything but straightforward
to translate data you
find in lab animals to human patients
have been a lot of explanations for why
it's so difficult to extrapolate data
from animals to humans but one of the
fact that that's often mentioned is
differences in design between the
clinical trial and the preceding animal
studies and I want to discuss a clear
example of the problems that might occur
if there are two large differences
between the animal studies and the
clinical trial that they first give a
little bit background information about
that example it's about applying
probiotics to acute pancreatitis
hepatitis is an inflammation of the
pancreas and the important complication
in clinical practice is secondary
infection of the pancreas and patients
who get such a secondary infection often
die the treatment that is currently
standards is the use of antibiotics but
it's not very clear whether they are
really effective against pancreatitis
and as was always the issue of bacterial
resistance and for that reason people
start searching for alternative
treatments and one of those alternatives
suggested recently was the use of
probiotics probiotics can be considered
beneficial bacteria products that
contain beneficial bacteria and basic
idea about behind using probiotics was
that the good bacteria in the probiotics
might help complete the bad bacteria
that caused the infection and in that
way it could solve the problem of
pancreatitis now to test that hypothesis
in 2004 a clinical trial was started in
the Netherlands it was called the pro
Patriot trial in this trial about 300
patients were enrolled half of them got
the experimental group experimental
treatment so the probiotics and half of
them got a placebo the probiotic product
that was used was called ecologic 641
and
product contains Birdos over a billion
bacteria and what's important is that it
contained multiple strains of bacteria
so not just one but multiple strains I
finally Basin scruffs the probiotics
twice daily for 28 days in the jejunum
in 2008 the results of the trial were
published and they were rather
unexpected first of all no differences
were found for any of the primary
outcomes they mainly looked at the
number of infectious complications in
the patients and there were no
differences between the probiotic group
and the perceiver group but what was
most striking is that the mortality was
significantly higher in the experimental
group so more patients died in the group
that got the probiotics then in the
control group and one of the questions
you could ask about this result it's
good this negative results have been
predicted if a closer look had been
taken at the animal studies that would
carried out before the trial and that's
exactly what we did in the context of a
systematic review we look at all animal
studies that studied the effect of
probiotics and pancreatitis and we got
some striking results I would say first
of all we saw that our quite some
metallurgical shortcomings any animal
studies but what was more striking
particularly in the context of my
lecture is that no animal study at a
design similar to the clinical trial we
saw that quite a few animal studies
applied the probiotics before inducing
pancreatitis any animals so they were
given profile XD rather than
therapeutically there were some that the
pilot officer but those used a different
product that was used in a clinical
trial we saw that in human patients the
jejunum was the route of administration
rest in most animal studies it was
applied orally or to the stomach and we
sort of quite a few animal studies you
single strain probably ethics rather
than multiple strains
I was one study that used the same
product associates in the clinical trial
but that study applied the probiotics
before inducing pancreatitis so again a
situation different from the clinical
trial and so the question remains at the
animal study being carried out with a
design similar to what we saw in a
clinical trial maybe the results would
also have been the same and we would
have concluded that it was not safe to
use to probably optics in pancreatitis
patients and the patients would not have
dies maybe the results were dissimilar
but because the experiment was never
carried out we don't know someone that
way a system LPD you can suggest which
animal studies certainly need to be done
before the steps to the clinic can be
taken another way in which systematic
reviews can help the design of animal
studies is in the selection of the
animal model flawless so find you've
decided what the research question of
your animal experiment is you need to
select the animal model that's most
suitable for answering that question an
animal model here not only refers to the
species or the strain of animal but also
I would say to the way in which disease
is induced in those animals then the
current situation that selection of
animal models is often not
evidence-based i would say in a
interview study that was carried out in
the field of cartilage tissue
engineering we found that the choice was
not evidence-based in two ways so other
reasons than the anticipated predictive
pneus of the model played a key role in
selecting animal models so for example
costs of housing animals ease of
handling were often more important than
the anticipated predictive pneus so
that's the reason why often small animal
models was used rather than more
probably more predictive large animal
models and the choice was also not
evidence-based in the sense that I was
not really a comparison between
different
actually suitable models and then next
best choice was made and here i would
say it against it many views could help
systematic videos can create a
comprehensive overview of available
models and you can map the advantages
and disadvantages of your different
models and then that way can really
provide the basis for selecting the most
appropriate model but even if the
intention of the systematic review is
not to provide such an offer for you a
city Madrid you can also help to provide
information that's crucial for making
such a choice what I show here is a
figure from a systematic review about
these effects of pregnancy on properties
of blood vessels the assessment review
was conducted by a gynecologist and so
we really wanted to understand the
mechanisms behind changes in blood
vessels during pregnancy but one of the
most striking findings in its
meta-analysis was that there are large
differences in response between
different strains of reps you can see
that the sprague-dawley rats response
rather differently to pregnancy than the
wistar rats so different mechanisms seem
to be involved and the wistar rats in
its response seemed to me more closely
related to healthy pregnancy in humans
and displayed re-read corresponds more
closely to preeclampsia and human
patients so if you want to conduct an
animal experiments about the effects of
pregnancy you need to be very clear
about whether you want to look at
healthy pregnancy or impaired pregnancy
because that has a large impact on which
train of red you could use most
appropriately so in this sense the
settlement of you can also help to
select an animal model for new
experiments finally I think system Ltd's
can help by improving the metallurgical
quality of animal experiments and again
I think it can be done in two ways
first of all set metal pieces can show
how important it is to take measures to
prevent bias and animal experiments
exactly they can suggest at which level
you should take those measures but first
why it is so important to take measures
to prevent bias in experiments here are
some results of a systematic review in
the field of stroke research where they
looked at the effect of a drug on
reduction in infarct volume and what
they did here is doing a subgroup
analysis in which they compares the
estimated effects in studies that
randomized the allocation of the animals
to the groups and studies that reported
that they did not randomized the
allocation of the animals to the groups
and you can clearly see that the studies
that is not randomized the allocation
overestimate the true effect of that
drug and it's even an overestimation of
about thirty percent so the actual
effects might be quite small and might
even be chemically irrelevant so this
clearly shows why it is so important to
take measures such as randomization and
blinding in your experiments as I
indicated in the beginning of my
presentation a standard step in a
systematic review as an assessment of
the study quality and here's a
presentation of the different types of
bias you look at in such a quality
assessment so you look at selection bias
performance by its detection bias and
attrition bias different levels in an
experiment in which buyers might be
introduced and so also different levels
at which randomization and blinding
should be applied so this composition of
the quality assessment insistently who
might also suggest aspects that you can
take into account in designing new
experiments to prevent bias so insult to
our different way
and which systematic videos can help can
support the design of new experiments
now if you want to know more about
systematic reviews are about the way in
which they can help the design of
experiments you can contact me on my
colleagues at circle thank you thank you
for the informative presentation both of
you before I get started on the question
and answer session I would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions with the cam and I'll
give you a moment to formulate questions
if there are no questions today I would
like to once again thank dr. Derek fry
and dr. Rob devries for their
presentations do you have any final
comments um I could all grab a few
questions oh I think we can probably do
that privately can I just interrupt you
for a second a question has just come in
do you find that oh it's a partial
partial so it's just part of the
sentence and so sorry it wasn't a
complete question so um okay so as a
reminder this presentation has been
approved for continuing educational
credits if you want to okay the person
says they are sending the full questions
so if you can wait just a second let's
give them a chance to see a fake if it
comes in quickly if not we'll conclude
so while there while they are
formulating their question I'll just
revise that as a reminder this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
on the get your free CD credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations please
select the CD button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through August 4 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to afford that
announcement your colleagues to may have
missed today's live event and the full
question has not commenced so i will pay
you next time good bye bye bye to